[Musik]
wie sieht denn der Alltag von einem
Bürgermeister in einer Stadt wie
krematorski jetzt
aussehen schauen Sie die laufenden
täglichen Fragen die die Infrastruktur
Objekte müssen nach wie vor
funktionieren weil nach wie vor 80.000
Einwohner in der Stadt wohnhaft bleiben
und alles mögliche Wasserversorgung
Strom Gasversorgung
und Transporte wie funktioniert das also
in unserem Hotel zum Beispiel gab es
kein Licht wie können die Leute nicht
abschalten aber wie gesagt
jetzt die ganze Ukraine dass das Licht
ab und zu ausgestaltet wird so
einmal pro Tag da haben wir Licht
abschalten nach hinten diversen Regionen
von
grammatos von zwei bis vier bis vier
Stunden aber wie gesagt das ist nicht so
extrem
wie es vor einem Monat war bis so unsere
Infrastruktur Objekte sich hier die
die die dieser Gelegenheit dann
angepasst haben gestern hatte die
russische Seite
auch angegriffen
hinein industriewerk gezielt und einige
raketenreste waren rund um dieses Werk
in kleinen Dörfern runtergefallen also
Gott sei Dank keine Wunde verletzt
ziehen die Angriffe hier auch darauf die
Infrastruktur zu zerstören schauen Sie
die
mehrfalls bis zu 80% da waren
zivilobjekt Infrastruktur Objekte
von Russen attackiert
den Grund versteht keiner warum sie das
machen
und die Leute die beiden den Leuten
Angst einzujagen keine Ahnung was fast
der Grund von diesen raketenanschlägen
ist aber die Konsequenz ist dass die
Infrastruktur lahmgelegt wird schauen
Sie also so weit sind wir mehr oder
weniger gut davon gekommen also es gab
keine großen Schäden also was die
Infrastruktur Objekte angeht aber wie
gesagt die Infrastruktur Objekte wie wir
das sehen in der ganzen Ukraine in
erster Linie untergefahr stehen
wie brisant ist diese Situation jetzt
also in welchem Moment des Krieges
befinden wir uns jetzt wie ernst ist die
Lage wenn man
eine bestimmte Spannung weil die
Frontlinie sich ein bisschen nähert aber
wie gesagt ich hoffe dass wenn
man damals überlebt haben das ist uns
auch weiterhin gelingt die Frontlinie
auf der Entfernung von 50 km zu halten
aber die Spannung die die die steigt ein
bisschen also jetzt sind alle gespannt
was
und die meisten Leute interessieren die
Frage was weiterhin Richtung machen und
geschieht also wir hoffen und wir sind
überzeugt dass das uns das gelingt auch
mit Hilfe von von unseren Partnern auf
Europa
haben sie noch Beziehungen zu Russland
keine
einzelne
Telefonate alle Kontakte gelöscht wann
noch junges
keine Schule Freunde keine Verwandte
mehr
alles Vergangenheit wie ist das
schauen Sie
ich meine Meinung ist das jeder Russe
dafür verantwortlich ist dass sie den
Putin so weit hin entweder hingetrieben
haben oder ihn nicht aufzuhalten haben
und so einfach sagen dass wir nichts
dazu dafür können mit zahlreichen
Telefonaten die es bei mir dann im
Vorjahre während
SMS mit den Schulungen wir können nichts
dafür und so weiter
die sind alle verschuldigt aus meiner
Sicht also das ist nicht putinskrieg
doch das ist putinskrieg aber die Russen
hätten ihn aufhalten sollen was sind
denn aus ihrer Sicht jetzt die
Perspektiven es wird ja in gerade in
Deutschland aber auch in anderen Ländern
die Debatte geführt es muss jetzt
endlich mal Friedensverhandlungen geben
manche sagen der Konflikt muss
eingefroren werden
was ist ihre Haltung aus meiner Sicht
ist das butieren solange wird die Russen
besiegen
solange er nicht aufzuhalten sein wird
aus meiner Sicht
die Russen nicht aufhalten werden wir
keine Frieden bekommen haben Sie das
Gefühl dass die Bevölkerung jetzt wieder
so reagiert dass Leute weggehen werden
oder sind die die
mai zum Beispiel nach dem alten aktiven
raketenanschlägen und Bombenanschlägen
als hier noch mit Flugzeugen attackiert
waren
da hatten so ungefähr 50.000 von
Einwohnern 170.000 waren zu dem
Zeitpunkt schon ausgereist und in der
letzten Seite sind wiederum 30.000
leider zurückgekehrt warum weil ich
leider weil je mehr Leute das ist in der
Stadt gibt und läuft
mehrere Meeres für die gefährlich ist
und umso mehr Hilfe diese Leute
angewiesen werden im Falle erfunden von
weiteren Bombenanschlägen jetzt ist
dieser Winter auch ein großes Problem
zwei Monate die wir noch weiterhin
überleben müssen also wie schaffen Sie
das die schauen Sie was wir eigentlich
hätten machen sollen haben wir noch
nichts mehr gemacht das heißt wir haben
wirklich sehr viele Generatoren besorgt
die uns eine zeitweile helfen können die
Stromausfälle oder blacko ist man heute
nennt äh leichter zu reden
also alles was nördliche gemacht werden
müssen ist gemacht worden das heißt sie
sind darauf vorbereitet oder sie sind
auch kommen
längere Zeit hinweg gedacht also wenn es
so Strom Ausfällen
kommen sollte wochenweise wochenlang
dann wird es schwierig zu überleben also
das heißt die zentrale Heizung fällt
fällt sofort auf also man kann zwei drei
Tage das kann man schon
heizen aber länger dauert es nicht die
Generatoren schaffen das nicht einmal ja
viele Menschen fragen sich jetzt ähm wie
kann man die Ukraine unterstützen am
besten die einzige Hilfe das sind die
auf jeden Fall das ist finanzielle
unterstützen weil die bildschätze von 30
bis 40% vor allem in unseren Gebieten
was Einkommen angeht verloren haben und
die zweite die wichtigste Hilfe das sind
offen
ohne Waffen mit kalaschnikowsk können
Sie
die Russen nie besiegen warum ist gerade
dieser Leopard so wichtig sie haben ja
schon die Ukraine hat ja schon ein
großes Paket an Waffen jetzt bekommen
schauen sie mit leoparster kann man dann
so wie ich das verstehe obwohl ich einen
zivile Person bin mit Leopard kann man
schon dann an eine nördliche
rückoffensive denken wenn wenn wenn wir
auf jeden Fall unser planen das und
unsere Armee und Präsident wir planen
und wir wollen alle
Betroffene Gebete
wiederum befreien was ist denn ihre
Perspektive wie lange dieser Krieg noch
dauern wird wenn das das Ziel ist meine
Meinung ist das ist auf jeden Fall
dieses Jahr noch andauern wird
durch diese militärberichte lesen also
schneller wird es leider nicht gelingen
dann aus meiner Sicht und was kommt dann
danach wie wird das dann für eine Stadt
und dann dann könnte es zu einem
möglichen Friedensabkommen wenn ihr das
nennen können dazu kommen auch zwischen
der Ukraine und Russland mit Hilfe von
wie gesagt europäischen Partner und USA
auf jeden Fall das dass sie Aldi Länder
in dieses logische Abkommen involviert
wird aber wie gesagt sobald ihr das
gelingt nicht so lange wird unsere alle
alle diese alle Flächen weil er Städte
dürfen so dass die nicht frei haben und
es ist auf jeden Fall immer
die deutsche Regierung hat ja große
Angst davor dass dieser Krieg
möglicherweise eskalieren könnte zu
einem weitergehenden Krieg mit Angriffen
auch auf Länder außerhalb der Ukraine
wladimir Putin hat ja jetzt noch mal
gedroht
genau mit Nuklearwaffen das tut er ja
immer wieder
versucht ist drauf nicht also hoffe ich
dass er
derart
den den sie nicht verloren hat das macht
ihnen keine Angst also mir macht das
schon keine Angst
in diesem Monaten jetzt erleben wir
gerade in den letzten Tagen einen großen
korruptions-skandal in der Ukraine das
ist jetzt auch ein großes Thema
sollte auch gelesen
schauen sie ist es gibt
korruptions-skandale weltweit also und
die Ukraine dann auch nicht die Ausnahme
sein aber sie haben sich damit auch erst
heute beschäftigt die ein bisschen
gelesen hat
wie schaffen das ich meine das fragen
wir uns mal wie schaffen das die Ukraine
immer wieder
weiterzumachen trotz dieser schlimmen
Situation unsere Motivation ist dass wir
für die Befreiung von
unseres Landes kämpfen
sterben weil versteht keiner wir kämpfen
und das hilft uns die Emotionen die
Motivation ist für die Ukraine das
einzige Land
zu befreien und ich denke das ist das
Wichtigste was man sieht
[Musik]